today's episode has been made possible
by
blinkist an app designed for those who
love to read but don't necessarily have
an abundance of time
the first hundred people to visit
blinkist.com
mythology and fiction will get unlimited
access for an entire week
as well as a 25 discount stick around
until the end to find out more about
today's great offer
vampires are everywhere you
pick up a book vampire you turn on the
tv
vampire you take a walk outside to get
away from it all
and well creepy guy down the road who
thinks he's a vampire
wherever you are in the world it's
likely you've heard stories and legends
of a vampire-like creature
with such a rich history to explore it's
fair to ask
where did vampires come from and why are
we so obsessed of them
the word vampire conjures numerous
images
from nosferatu and christopher lee's
dracula
to latex wearing goths with guns
whatever these are meant to be
and even glittering abominations we'd
all like to pretend
never existed what we see in pop culture
has certainly been
influenced by the legends of old and
those are what we will focus on today
before the 18th century the term vampire
never really
existed much like the hysteria
surrounding the witch trials
a series of odd disappearances weird
markings on corpses and suspicious
activities around graveyards and
cemeteries
led to accusations of vampirism the
majority of these reports
came from the balkans and eastern europe
with each country and region having its
own iteration of what we would consider
a vampire
some of the oldest examples worldwide
include
figures such as lamastu lilith lamia
and the impusa who are all female but
they aren't necessarily the undead
creatures you'd associate with vampires
they're more demon or succubus-like
in romania and other parts of eastern
europe you have tales of the strigoi
spirits who had risen from the grave who
could only survive through the blood of
others
if needed they could turn invisible and
transform into animals
not too different from today's vampires
who can transform into bats and
other creatures variations of the word
strigoi can be found in numerous other
languages in greek and latin the word
stryx
once referred to nocturnal bird women
who would feed off the blood and flesh
of
children this was also the same in
france
in romanian the term does literally mean
one who has risen from the grave
it's likely these myths refer to
something more akin to a blood parasite
than the seductive vampires were used to
the earliest account of a suspected
strigoi came in 1656
in where we now consider modern day
croatia
a villager began terrorizing his town
the man in question was yuri grando
and had died earlier that year the
legends state that grando
rose from the grave and would knock on
doors around the village
each house he visited would experience a
death within the next few days
this continued for 16 years after grando
had
originally died until the villagers
found a way to kill him
one night he appeared before his widowed
wife who said his corpse was gasping for
air but still maintained a sinister grin
the priest responsible for burying
grando 16 years earlier
led a group of villagers on a quest to
explain these disappearances
when they came across the vampire one
man tried to impale him in the heart
with a wooden pole but his skin was
tough
the pole bounced off and splintered the
priest then took out his cross
behold jesus christ you vampire
stop tormenting us he yelled and the
vampire
fled the next morning they dug up his
coffin
only to find a perfectly preserved body
inside
with a smile on his face they tried
stabbing him in the heart again
only this time with a wooden stake but
they couldn't penetrate the skin
and so the priest performed an exorcism
another villager took a saw
and decapitated the vampire noting the
skin around his neck
offered much less resistance the vampire
screamed out in pain and blood poured
from his wound
with the vampire dead the village could
finally
rest after this story there were several
precautions taken
and methods used by the romanians and
others
to protect themselves from the strigoi
there was a common belief that some
men particularly redheads could return
in the form of an animal
and sneak into houses where they would
feed off young women
in order to stop this their coffins
would be nailed shut
and in some cases they would even stake
the corpse in the heart
before they were buried if they
suspected someone had risen from their
grave
they employed a host of methods to
ensure the dead
stayed dead first they would dig up the
body
its heart removed and cut into two a
nail would then be driven into its
forehead
and a clove of garlic placed under its
tongue
lastly the body would be moved to face
downwards
believing if the strigoi ever woke they
would be sent
straight down to the afterlife there was
the belief that one could become a
strigoi
while still alive if certain conditions
were met
they also divided the strigoi into three
main categories
a witch a living strigoi and a strigoi
who had risen from the dead
whilst on the topic of romanian history
you have perhaps their most famous
historical figure
vlad dracul or vlad tepas
we also can't forget his nickname vlad
the impaler
which refers to his favorite pastime of
impaling his enemies on pikes and
watching as they die slowly
some argue that vlad the impaler was the
biggest influence for bram stoker's
dracula
whilst others don't believe this is true
it is interesting however to see the
similarities in terms of
name location and bloodlust
some other undead european creatures
include
the nordic draga which can be found
protecting
tombs the balkan dampier which is born
from the union of a male vampire and a
human female and the albanian lugat
which is your typical gruesome can't
stand sunlight but enjoys flying around
and seducing people into the darkness
type of vampire
in australia according to aboriginal
myth there existed
a creature called the yaramayahu
a small red froglike man who hid
in trees the yaramayahu has an
extremely large head with suckers on the
end
of its hands and feet it also prefers to
do most of its hunting during the day
when unsuspecting travellers decided to
rest under its tree
it would jump down and drain the victim
of their blood before swallowing them
whole
if that wasn't weird enough it then
takes a nap and regurgitates the victim
when the person wakes their skin has a
noticeably red
tint and they are smaller than before
this process is repeated until they
become a yaramayahu
in western africa you can find legends
of a creature with iron teeth
long red hair and hooks for feet
the asan bosam hangs from trees and
attacks its victim from
above piercing their neck with its hooks
and draining their blood
in the philippines you have the
manananggal
a hideous creature that is capable of
detaching its torso from the rest of its
body
and sprouting bat-like wings much like
lamastu the mananang girl likes to prey
on pregnant women
using its elongated tongue to suck out
the hearts of fetuses
luckily it does have an aversion to salt
garlic and holy water
when it separates from its lower half is
when the creature is
most vulnerable rubbing crushed garlic
salt or ash onto its lower half is
thought to be lethal
the upper half then cannot rejoin the
lower half
and if it fails to do so by sunrise the
creature will perish
in malaysia you have the panangalan a
ghostly spirit who
floats through the air with her entrails
hanging beneath her
where the panangalan differs from the
manananggal
is the fact that they are living beings
a mortal woman who practices black magic
performing a ritual in a vat or bath of
vinegar
allowing them to take this ghostly form
during the night
and return to their regular body in the
morning
in china you have the hyachi reanimated
corpses whose joints are so stiff
they hop around looking for victims to
kill so they can absorb
their life force like traditional
vampires they prefer to rest in dark
places during the day
as there are so many different stories
of creatures around the world
defining a vampire can get confusing
but the one recurring trait you will see
is the need to consume the life force of
other living creatures
in order to sustain themselves the other
traits vary wildly depending on location
but in a fictional context they have
been somewhat streamlined
and there are certain things we've come
to expect
such as vampires fearing sunlight and
having fangs they use to feed
an aversion to crucifixes garlic and
silver is also very common
along with having no reflection not
being able to stand on consecrated
across running water or enter someone's
home without being invited in
first in terms of what makes a vampire
special
they are fast strong and much harder to
kill than a regular person
they can also fly and compel humans and
animals to serve them
so i guess we come back to the questions
we asked in the beginning
why are we obsessed with stories of
vampires
and why did we see this change from
repulsive
undead monsters to handsome or
seductive charmers i think it comes down
to our fascination
or fear of mortality vampires
essentially cheat death or at least
they're given a second life
granted it can also be seen as a curse
as for why vampires take on a more
seductive or romantic role
19th century fiction certainly
contributed to this
john william polidoris the vampire
written in 1819
is considered by many as the start of
vampire romance
in the fantasy genre vampires slowly
began to assume the role of the
anti-hero before bram stoker published
his dracula in 1897
the quintessential gothic horror
featuring the most famous vampire of all
after this we have a wave of fiction and
movies where vampires are very much
the anti-hero or the charismatic villain
this only further adds to the vampire
appeal
they can be these terrifying monsters
who want nothing more than to satisfy
their thirst or they can have human
qualities
a tortured soul seeking redemption
vampires are also loners most of the
time which is something people can
relate to
as feeling alienated misunderstood and
like we don't belong
it's something most of us experience at
some point in our lives
especially when we're younger which may
explain why vampires are so popular in
young adult fiction
maybe you have a different take or maybe
you just like to share your favorite
vampire book or movie
as i mentioned earlier today's video has
been sponsored by blinkist
if you're like me and you enjoy learning
new things but struggle to find the time
and motivation to commit to a
series of long books then this is
definitely the app for you
blinkist takes thousands of non-fiction
books and condenses the key information
into 15-minute segments that you can
read
or listen to in your own time it's
extremely easy to access on your phone
which means you can continue learning
while doing the laundry
and other mundane activities they have
over 12 million
active users as well as an extensive
library of over
3400 books spanning across numerous
genres
from finance self-help and politics
to history nature and science
there is something for everyone i've
personally just finished listening to
the rise and fall of dinosaurs because
dinosaurs are awesome
but some of you may prefer mythology by
edith hamilton which is a great starting
point for anyone
interested in greek and roman mythology
the first hundred people who go to
blinkist dot com slash
mythology and fiction will receive
unlimited access for an entire week
as well as an additional 25 discount if
you decide
you want a full membership the seven day
trial
is completely free and you can cancel at
any time during those seven days
if you decide it's not for you but if
you enjoy reading
it certainly will be as always
i've been your host mythology and
fiction explained
you